this morning President Biden scrambling
to prevent a full-blown Bank Panic as
fears of a contagion effect grow the
president forced to take emergency
measures after two of the biggest
Financial failures in U.S history
Silicon Valley Bank the first to
collapse followed by the implosion of
Signature Bank both catered to the tech
startup world the president trying to
reassure Americans that their deposits
are safe while making sure to blame
Republicans
thanks to the quick action of my
Administration over the past few days
Americans can have confidence that the
banking system is safe when no losses
will be borne by the taxpayers during
the Obama Biden Administration we put in
place tough requirements on banks
unfortunately the last Administration
rolled back some of these requirements
president what do you know right now
about why this happened and can you
assure Americans that there won't be a
ripple effect
Mr President
should all depositors be protected at
all banks and the president getting
praise from his former press secretary
jensaki for getting up early to give a
speech before the stock market opened
it's important to note President Biden
does nothing at 9am he is a night owl so
the fact that he is doing this at 9am
anyway speaks to how vital the White
House recognizes it is for him to have
his voice out there conveying that to
the American public and the banks facing
criticism for being more focused on the
green agenda rather than the bottom line
at the Administration has pushed many of
these Banks into more concern about
global warming than they do about
shareholder return
and these Banks badly run because
everybody is focused on diversity and
all of the woke issues and not
concentrating on one thing they should
which is
shareholder returns
all right Harold Ford Jr got us kicked
off in the Green Room explaining things
from your point of view and it you
understand this pretty much better than
anybody I've talked to today so let me
give you the floor I need to get some
more people to talk to go ahead what do
you think of all of this and what the
president's done today so this is a bad
situation it's unfortunate
um that we find ourselves with two Banks
having to be having to be closed uh and
the federal government having the FED
having to come in I think the president
what I took away from him was really two
or three things one that every deposit
that all of us have be it small big
depositors big medium-sized businesses
small businesses everyone's deposit is
going to be protected and insured for
one year at least number two
um it's saying sounds like the night the
FED is going to try to figure out even
more and more what happened at Silicon
Valley Bank and it sounds like they're
even trying to sell the bank again I
think even some of the criticism we
heard in the opening from some which I
think some of that some of that is
legitimate many wish that there had been
a private Market solution to this and
the federal government would not have
had to come into the FED would not have
had to come in to help but I would
contend to those that say that when we
got to Sunday night and there not been a
deal uh that it was I think appropriate
for the fed and I hope in a bipartisan
way Congress and the Senate can agree
with this this was the the best solution
to a really really bad challenge or bad
problem it would have been a terrible
thing had we had a bank run a continued
bank run today in a serious way and if
the market had responded negatively
three there's a lot of political
appropriating blame to go around I wish
people wouldn't do that right now I wish
that anything that has been passed over
the last several years to try to address
this issue because some may know around
the table we stress test banks that are
more than 250 billion dollars in size
this bank was 200 billion in size we
passed rules several years ago to help
reduce some of the the rules again that
Banks like this have to face smaller
Banks because the smaller Banks said
it's too expensive for us to try to
comply with all of this we clearly now
need to re-look at that and see if
that's the right way to do it is if
there's a better balance of protections
for depositors and more importantly a
better protection for taxpayers I think
in intermediate long term we've got to
think about what does this mean for
banks if everybody's deposits are
insured even the insured and the
uninsured and all that many really means
if you have over 250 000 in the bank as
an individual or business are we willing
as are we prepared as a nation say all
of that's going to be protected should
there be some protections for small
business and medium-sized businesses who
run their business operations payments
and other things including employee how
they pay their employees through these
Banks I think we should have that
conversation I think at the real right
now at this moment I think the
government has done what the government
should have done it was the least
expensive way to try to help address
this problem and I hope going forward
that everybody that's voted in the past
for things they thought was right they
thought were right look now and see if
indeed the things they passed or what's
best for our system one thing you said
in the right before we got here was a
really good point is that thinking back
to 2008 is that the phone was not really
what we used to do our banking I
remember no wait when I left the White
House I didn't even have a Twitter one
of the bank was done as much by people
going right into their accounts on their
smartphones and how quickly it happened
because as you were pointing out this
bank was solvent as of Wednesday and
that all unraveled but Jesse um as much
as our esteemed friend who we'd love to
see at the table
um would like to see politics not play a
role it's plays a role it is it's a part
of the system that we have and we're
going to see politics well first of all
it's good to be back around the table
and I'm glad the night owl uh didn't
take any questions on the one of the
biggest bank collapses in U.S history I
would have liked him to answer a
question but you know maybe Ducey didn't
yell loud enough
tell me where I'm going wrong here you
have a president who spent more money
than any other president in the entire
world and just showered this industry
with cash I'm talking Silicon Valley I'm
talking these San Francisco people more
money went out the door to these people
than ever for solar for everything this
is a big solar financing Bank
and all of a sudden we have record
inflation and these guys are sitting on
piles and piles of money and they didn't
see that the Fed was going to have to
raise rates
so they made a bet that the rates were
going to not go up oops the rates go up
and now all of a sudden they're blown up
and they say guys we're gonna need all
that money back because there's going to
be a financial crisis well how do we
know they're always saying there's going
to be a run on the banks if you don't
bail us out there's going to be a run we
got to get the money the donors and the
bankers always get the money don't they
they always squeeze the money out of the
politicians because they scare them
we're not going to have any more
donations left if we don't get some of
that money back so this this company
it is a woke back despite what you said
in the Green Room they're very into this
social justice investing stuff they're
all concerned with with gender and
everything even as the banks collapsing
they're still holding seminars on gender
ideology and they're getting bonuses on
the Friday that they blow up and the CEO
is selling what 3.5 6.5 million dollars
in stock two weeks before like he had no
idea this was going to happen the San
Francisco fed share had no idea isn't it
the the San Francisco fed chairs that
have some sort of visibility on the
stupid Bank they're just going to blow
this up you agree good I agree and what
this does I thought you were only
supposed to insure up to a quarter
million in deposits now you can lose a
quarter billion and Uncle Sam's gonna
come out and shovel money at you what
does that do to everybody they could
just throw money around there's there's
just no safety this is a safety net for
the bankers that's this is a social
safety net for Bankers everybody else he
wouldn't even pay for hotel rooms for
the people of East Palestine and all of
a sudden he's just like here take some
money there's going to be a background
goodbye I don't agree I agree with
everything you've said the only thing I
disagree with we should protect the
positives and that's what I think is the
right thing one thing interesting that
came out of this Kennedy was that you
have Elizabeth Warren and Bernie Sanders
saying but the banks will pass the fees
of the higher they'll make up the cost
of having to do all of this by passing
on those fees to customers it's like why
don't they think that that is also true
when they want to raise taxes on
everybody yeah and and by the way a lot
of the regular regulations that
Elizabeth Warren has been pushing uh for
15 years the banks are complying with
that by passing on more fees in
different ways but you know I look at
this yes it is absolutely political but
it's also you know a big part of the
blame here in addition to the people
running and mismanaging that bank and
shame on them it's the fed and this
Administration has been so incredibly
irresponsible with inflation so what has
happened is they have had to raise rates
so quickly that part of the economy was
bound to break and and here was the
weakest part of the banking sector
because they were these two Banks were
so concentrated in crypto and Venture
capitalism and they weren't Diversified
they had some treasury notes but when
the bond market collapsed the banks were
sure to follow suit because on paper
they looked good but actually their debt
exceeded the equity that they had by
quite a bit so the FED now either has to
continue raising rates to Stave off
inflation which is getting worse or you
know they go back and inflation sets the
economy on fire because there will be no
end in sight for how high that could go
money's going to be more expensive
people are going to lose their homes and
unemployment is sure to follow
unfortunately okay Brian what you got
well first off congratulations to Harold
I thought Jesse was yelling at you you
didn't take it that way so you're a
bigger man for a while I thought there's
going to be a duel but it wasn't that
way a couple of things when do you
notice uh the first thing you hear from
President Biden is uh it's Trump's fault
the first thing you saw with the balloon
well the balloons passed during Trump
Administration the first thing with the
railroad well uh you know Donald Trump
said don't put brakes on railroad trains
remember when it rained right it was
Trump's fault so I'm like what what a
it's everything you don't want your kid
to do is blame somebody else not take
responsibility the other thing is I also
thought it's really important that this
this guy Greg Becker takes a Silicon
Valley Bank Chiefs sells 3.6 million
dollars worth of company stock a couple
of days before he knows we're going to
be talking about this he knows it's
going to be news but it's still it's
worth it because he's eventually going
to get a pass people get their bonuses
we all get screwed also right across the
street I didn't know there was a
republic bank right there so I don't
know if it's because it's raining or but
right now it has dropped 67 in value if
there was a run in the banks there's no
line so I think that's good but that
could be next I got my money out there
right oh yeah I should have
comprehension not good for me that's
where we started Harold I know we have
to go guys but just one quick question
what about this guy selling the stock
two weeks beforehand look I have no I'm
learning like you're learning there's
going to be an investigation of this and
uh they're going to get to the bottom of
they can Claude back if he if he did
that knowing that this was going to
happen then he'll face some consequences
I think it's also important though the
big banking system in our country is as
capitalized and as protected as it has
ever been so the big banking centers
these are the ones that are trying to
consolidate to those four big Banks if
all the Regionals evaporate a lot of the
a lot of those big Banks can't buy the
little Banks anymore it's against it and
also remember during covet it was the
little Banks who were able to get the
PPP loans out remember that one in
Mississippi
is YouTube page this is the only way
that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now